lucy oh wow
lucy was like indiana jones back there
like rolling through the door grabbing
the whip
hi guys oh there's so many doggies here
today
i am so excited okay well
um you know i just i'm excited for this
show
and on one note i want to say is that
earlier this week we talked about
how decorating early for
christmas is actually good for mental
wellness okay i don't know who does
these studies
but i gotta tell ya my halls are already
decked and i'm feeling really good
so maybe they're right that's right
that's me and my tree yeah we put a bird
on it that's right
and uh we have all our ornaments up and
our christmas stockings and my girls and
i took like tins of glitter and just
like
chucked it on the tree and i have to say
i feel mentally well yeah
and there's so many different kinds of
people that come on this show which was
exactly my goal when we started this
show
i was like can we have people of note
who we'd all be star struck by can we
have human interest do we need to
know about these people in the world can
there be people who are on social media
and they're famous because they put
themselves out there and everybody's
responding
well our next guest is just that jess
rhona is a grooming
guru and she has pampered pooches
for people like katy perry and zoe
deschanel
i have to say i would give anything to
have
lucy and douglas go to her but here's
what you need to know her instagram
account is full of like
these slow motion videos of dogs
and i just was blown away
check this one out
[Music]
okay anyway um oh and this cutie with
god save the queen
[Music]
and now jess is hosting a brand new show
called hot dog the tasking groomers to
take their canines into k10s
take a look you could have beveled the
feet a little bit higher
but i think you really achieved the look
you were going for and she just looks
darling yeah thank you yeah and i love
that you use
thinning shears that's my favorites
i love these you can't go wrong they're
magic
wow yeah the connection of it all
so jess rona joins us now from her la
salon
but check this out her show sold to
hbo max that's the big leagues so
please welcome someone i personally am
highly invested in
just rona
hi everything you're saying about me
i cannot believe this is my life when i
originally started making the videos
i was kind of like in a low place in my
life and i just grabbed my phone because
i was listening to music as i was
grooming dogs
the music crescendoed as i was
blow-drying a pekingese named noodle and
her ears flew up
and i just i was like oh this is
cinematic this is beautiful
so i just started making these videos
and i never thought
anything about it until i got people's
feedback
it's true it's like i see your wood
paneled walls and
you choose music and there's this like
blow back
and there is this watermark style i feel
like i could tell your video from like
anywhere in the world they'd be like oh
that's a jess rhona video
i feel like i'm watching dogs do what i
think
people did in the 70s thank you so much
well we're going to go through this show
and throughout the show
you're going to groom cashew yes
for sure i do kind of like a japanese
style on her
and just like an all-over shaping she's
not getting an overhaul but she's
definitely going to get a nice
look now will you please look at lucy
and tell me
stay okay what would you do with lucy
would you
groom her in any way would you shave her
would you bow her pluck
i would never shave her i would honor
her coat
so i would deep condition her and give
her an argan oil face mask
and maybe just put it all over and i
would just hydrate her and de-shed her
brush her teeth by her nails maybe tidy
her feet but i wouldn't
really cut a lot of hair maybe a little
shaving
yeah because she is kind of like a
wookie
[Applause]
yeah she's gorgeous her coloring is so
pretty
thank you and this is douglas douglas is
gonna be 13. i've had him since he was
eight weeks old and he's a rescue
what would you do with douglas i feel
like i would just
de-shed and hydrate the coat really well
you know once you when you have a dog
that doesn't need a lot of hair cutting
there's still a lot of
spa you can do spa treatments you can do
on a dog you know and if you're like at
home and you're watching this and you're
like ugh
my dog sheds everywhere is there
something that can be done about that or
is that a myth
no totally go to a professional
groomer once a month we have these horse
dryers that blow off the dead coat
so if you're sitting there brushing your
dog for seven hours it's just not gonna
do
much and it's also not great for their
skin i mean what is there any message
before we go to you know break and come
back and check in with you throughout
the show
is there any wisdom you would want to
impart to
dog owners who are stuck at home
and want to do something a little
special
and something we hadn't thought to do
with our dogs for the holiday
and it's to get a little bit of tulle
wrap around your dog's collar
and just make like a cute little bow and
that's like a fun thing you can do that
maybe
people haven't thought of just a little
bit of tulle all right well we're going
to check in with you throughout the show
to see how cashews look is being form
shaped and enhanced thank you jess
for picking up a blow dryer
putting some music on and seeing what
was possible
for all of us to meditate
and yet groove to like it's like sexy
meditation
i know it sounds weird but it it just is
that's my new thing
sexy meditation baby sexy meditation
with jess rhona at the start of the show
we met
dog grooming guru and star of the new
show
on hbo max called hot dog
it's just rona and jess would agreed to
do a live doggy makeover throughout the
show and now it's time for the big
reveal this was cashew before
and jess what are you ready to show us
with cashew now
oh yes much more fluffed much more
groomed absolutely
go for it
i love it and jess i mean are you
so excited you have a show on hbo max
that's like
you know yeah no idea
like i started off as an actress and a
comedian
and this was my side hustle it was never
supposed to be a thing
this took over your life it's like when
one path
you know you're walking down and then
you do as you said a side hustle and it
becomes
the star totally and i do think that you
bring
so much joy to people's life and thank
you for coming on the show
oh my god jess i just i want to do lots
of 70s blow dries and
music and dances and i just love you so
let this be the beginning of a beautiful
friendship thank you so much for coming
on the show
thank you to our vffs and all of our
four-legged friends that came to hang
out today
and we will see you next time thank you
you